Speaker 1: You're not going to
believe this because it sounds crazy.
But it's true. We don't know the reason why.
We don't know if it was an accident or if it
was deliberate. But the a Lago surveillance
footage room from which important surveillance
footage related to Donald Trump's handling
of classified documents that he stole.
Has been flooded because a Trump employee at Mar a
Lago drained the pool into the surveillance room.
It sounds unbelievable. Bess Levin has a
piece in Vanity Fair about it called We're
Sure There's a Totally Innocent Reason. The
Mar a Lago surveillance footage room flooded
amidst the DOJ's Trump investigation. Here is
a report from CNN explaining what happened.
Listen to how insane this is.
Speaker 2: And what I am
learning and have confirmed is that one
of the things prosecutors are inquiring
about is that there was a flood at Mar a Lago
back October, specifically, one of the men,
a maintenance worker who was captured on some
of this video surveillance tape helping to move
some of the boxes in and out of that storage
room. He drained the pool at Mar a Lago in
October. And when that happened, it flooded a
room and that room had it equipment in it that
had surveillance footage. And so we don't know.
Speaker 1: Guys, it's, uh, can you believe this?
Speaker 2: And it's not clear if prosecutors
believe that this flood was intentional.
It could have been a mistake. But it is one of
these things that adds in to this constellation
of things that just are suspicious to prosecutors
have raised questions. And we do know, too,
that prosecutors have received some testimony
and some answers about what happened there.
And some of the testimony is that the video
surveillance system wasn't damaged in this
flood. But all of these questions are going back
to did Donald Trump give some sort of direction
or did these people who were working for him,
this maintenance worker and another man who
was captured on tape moving boxes while not of his
body, man, were they taking steps to inquire about
the surveillance footage or was it just sort of.
Speaker 1: All right, you get it? Okay. So at this
point, we certainly can't say Trump ordered
anyone. Hey, listen, how about this? Drain
the pool into the surveillance room and let's
damage all of the equipment so they can't get
the footage. In fact, there was that one assertion
made in this report that that was not actually the
cause of the surveillance footage going missing.
It went missing for whatever reason. We still
don't know. But apparently some are claiming that
it was not a result of the pool being drained
into the surveillance room, but it certainly
doesn't sound good. There's a very good tweet
thread from Brian Allen, who says an employee at
Donald Trump's Mar a Lago residence drained the
resort's swimming pool last October and ended up
flooding a room where computer servers containing
surveillance video logs were kept. Sources
familiar with the matter told CNN While it is
unclear if the room was intentionally flooded or
if it happened by mistake, the incident occurred
amid a series of events that federal prosecutors
found suspicious. That's the understatement of the
century. At least one witness has been asked
by prosecutors about the flooded server room
as part of the federal investigation into Trump's
handling of classified documents, according to one
of the sources. The incident, which has not been
previously reported, came roughly two months after
the FBI retrieved hundreds of classified
documents from Florida residents. And as
prosecutors obtained surveillance footage to track
how White House records were moved around the
resort. Prosecutors have been examining any effort
to obstruct the Justice Department's investigation
after Trump received a subpoena in May 22 for
classified documents. So, listen, I want to be
really up front with everybody at this point.
We cannot say that this was a deliberate act or
that it was ordered by Donald Trump. You know,
sometimes in situations with multiple levels of
people involved, they will keep the boss isolated
for plausible deniability. And so it could have
been someone else who said, listen, we're not
even going to tell Trump we're doing this,
but just drain the pool into the surveillance
room and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. We just
it's all speculation right now, but it just has
guilt dripping all over it. And there are those
who will say, David, this is just too much of
a coincidence. It's too much of a coincidence
that in the immediate period where Donald Trump
clearly lied about what he did with the documents,
so then investigators said, all right, well,
you've got security cameras. Let's get a look at
the footage. They slow walk providing the footage.
And in the meantime, the server room floods,
although again, in their defense, they're saying
that's not the reason why we can't get you the
surveillance footage. It always stinks to high
heaven. It's yet another one of these incredible
coincidences. But we can't say for sure that it
was deliberate and maybe it wasn't. Maybe it was
just incompetence. I mean, let's let's be very
honest. Trump ran on I will hire the best people.
And then he hired terrible people. And when
it blows up in his face, he says, Well,
they lied to me to get hired or whatever
the case may be. We know, bottom line,
we know Trump doesn't hire the best people. And
maybe that applies to the same person who was both
in charge of the pool and moving the documents. I
don't know. I don't know why the same person would
be involved in both of those things. It's all
extraordinarily weird. I want to hear from you.
Does this seem suspicious or is it probably
nothing? Let me know in a YouTube comment and
an email in a tweet wherever. And make sure, of
course, that you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel, folks. We're pushing to 2 million
subscribers, and I would love for you to be one
of the 2 million. I've mentioned this before.
I will mention it again. Last month we just
got very strong numbers for May on the YouTube
channel. This is pretty interesting from a data
perspective. In May, almost 4 million different
people watched video clips on YouTube, almost 4
million like 3.8 million. But we have only 1.7
million YouTube subscribers. What this means is
that there are 2.1 million people out there who
watched clips but didn't subscribe. Remember,
you don't have to get notified of every video just
because you've subscribed. But it really helps us
direct the YouTube algorithm to direct people
to us. When you do hit that subscribe button,
so please do it. Let's go to 2 million. Let's
take a very quick break and then we're going
to continue. Chris Christie, folks. I
have good things to say about Republican
Chris Christie. He had a very strong town
hall last night. After this short break.